We earlier discussed quality measures,
and now you'll see why.
Providers demonstrate that they have
achieved Meaningful Use Stage One
by submitting measures in three
categories, core measures,
menu set measures, and
clinical quality measures.
There are 15 mandatory core measures.
Providers must also submit
five of ten menu set measures,
as well as six clinical
quality measures.
Three of these are mandatory, and
providers can select the other
three from a list of 41.
The core measures are divided
into the four groups shown here.
Improve quality, safety, and efficiency,
and reduce health disparities.
Engage patients and families.
Improve care coordination and
privacy and security.